each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so today brian is going to talk to us
about some of their experiences of
applying those tools to do your life
code out there right alright so thank
you been what I'm going to talk about
today is joint work that I'd done with
Gary McGraw and sammy goes from from
digital and boy am i allowed now if you
want to bump that down a little bit okay
maybe that'll work a little better for
me so it's really about uh sort of in
the broadest sense advice and whose
advice you ought to take and there's no
shortage of advice in the world and if
you think about all the people who offer
you advice like your you know your auto
mechanic and your dentist and your
doctor and Oprah and your mother and if
you if you tried to you know take all
the advice that you were getting then
you probably wouldn't have any time to
do anything that you wanted to do and so
that wouldn't be any good and I'll tell
you when you get more specific and you
start thinking about the security realm
there is absolutely no shortage of
advice about security so the question is
whose security advice should you take
and where in the heck did that security
advice come from in the first place and
our assertion at this point is that a
lot of that security advice was made up
and it was made up because there was no
easy way over the last 10 years to know
what you needed to do in order to build
security into a piece of software so
people had to take their best guess and
then go try some stuff and we've now
done that for long enough that we can go
back and say okay what happened and so
this we talked about the people who just
sort of made advice up out of thin air
as being the alchemists and what we're
trying to do here is say maybe we're
ready for a little bit of empiricism
when it comes to building security into
we're and we can go and look at what
actually happens to people who took some
of that advice different different
pieces of advice and figure out where
they ended up so I'm I use the language
of revolutionaries at the at the top of
this slide because unfortunately some of
the content of this slide still is
revolutionary to a lot of the world we
take it to be sort of the starting line
so things like you're not going to be
able to get security right for a piece
of software by sprinkling some
cryptography on it and you're not going
to be able to get security right by
adding in some sort of single mechanism
that you hang over on this side of the
software and then it takes care of the
whole problem for you because software
is an emergent property of the code and
if you're not with me on this stuff
already I don't really expect that you
guys have we're going to have a problem
with this but some people do and they're
just not ready to talk about this stuff
yet so if basically the starting line
here is people who are trying to build
security into the code that they write
and the question is then what's the
right way to do that what what
activities do you need to carry out as
part of building a piece of software in
order to be able to make some sort of
case are in order to sleep well at night
maybe that's the easiest way to
summarize it all right so here's where
I'm coming at this thing from um I
started out doing this kind of work
working in software security because i
liked sort of swinging around on other
people's code like it was monkey bars
and telling him stuff they didn't
already know about the software that
they that they were producing and so i
just liked it because it was fun and you
know so i advertise to people that maybe
i can help them find vulnerabilities or
protect their code against attack or for
the security evangelists tell them maybe
you could get some help from the people
who are writing the software was getting
security right and sort of harness some
of that developer horsepower and address
the the software security problem um but
every time I make an assertion like this
about
sort of interesting algorithm I've got
or or product that I've got I've got to
put a little asterisk by it it basically
says you know you can use what I just
did in order to get better security but
you've got to use it as part of the
bigger picture in other words you can't
buy a product from fortify and the
moment you sign that check now your
security is better you've got to apply
it in the right way okay that's that's
that's too i think pretty easy to accept
but the question is then what do you
mean apply it in the right way how
exactly do i do i use this stuff and so
now I'm put in the position of being one
of those people who has to give advice
Lou okay so so what do you say what do
you what do you say to somebody here's
here's what I say to him I say there are
a lot of good advice givers out there
pick one and the two big ones that I
point out are generally a McGraw and the
stuff that he wrote down in software
security building security in and then
Howard Lipner and I like them both and I
like them for somewhat different reasons
so maybe it maybe I should start with uh
with Howard and Lipner what I like is
you know here's a set of here's a
software development lifecycle and here
are things you overlay on that software
development lifecycle and what's the
real punch line here is and we did it we
did it and we know what happens when you
do it and we can point to oh the fact
that we're happier now with our security
than we were before because we did this
stuff but it's really easy for people to
turn around and say yeah yeah okay maybe
that works for you microsoft but we
don't do things the microsoft way so how
do we know that any of this stuff is is
relevant to us so while i like about
MacGraw as he comes by and he tries to
do a much more generic version of a very
similar thing and in many ways comes out
at a lot of the same points as looking
at the microsoft stl everybody says you
need to think about security before you
start building stuff you need to think
about security as part when you're
designing the software you need to think
about security when you're implementing
and you need to swing all the way
through the ball and make sure that you
keep thinking about security once you've
actually released a product or deployed
some code right so the olas guys have
their clasp methodology and it does many
of those same things so if you step back
a little way and you squint you see
actually a lot of the alchemy starts to
kind of kind of look the same even
though the the breeds and stripes may
not may not line up exactly so basically
I what I say to people is you need to
pick one of these and then we can fit in
a product or a technique into the
whatever methodology you choose okay so
that got me off the hook quite honestly
for a good year or two so and not a not
a bad one but you know I started
collecting started collecting questions
that I wasn't answering so well at least
from my perspective and here's here are
some of them so you say there are these
steps that you need to carry out in
order to build security into code are
they the same steps no matter what piece
of software I'm writing because I'll
tell you I've got the the piece of
software that is the flagship product
for the company and I've got the piece
of software that allows me to display
the cafeteria lunch menu to people who
work in the building and you're telling
me I need to build those pieces of
software the same way hmm that doesn't
that doesn't ring right at least not at
first blush and then there's the
question of how do I know any of this
stuff is going to work how do i convince
internal stakeholders that they should
give me budget or people to do to do any
of this work can yet can you prove it to
me somehow um after that it's like okay
well you know I bought it I've got
things up and running and you know I got
some fortify in there and fortify helped
me find a bunch of vulnerabilities in my
code do I have to fix them do I have to
fix all of them do I oh if I only have
to fix some of them which some of them
do I have to fix hmm um hey you know I
turns out that i don't actually build
all of my own code i buy some code from
from some commercial vendors I
Commission some of that code and it gets
written for me in India and I and I
bring it back I just sort of point and
click and download some of it off the
internet in the form of open source what
the heck am I supposed to do with all of
those different vectors that are that
are bringing me code I'll tell you none
of these questions for me we're answered
out of the books that I that I showed
you on that on the on the previous page
which had some good fundamental ideas
about how how maybe security should be
built into software but don't really
talk to speak directly to any of these
issues and so my interest or my focus
started to shift a little bit from this
notion that what we need to do is build
security into a development lifecycle to
we need to help people build a software
security initiative and when I say
software I mean anywhere that software
comes from and when I say initiative I
mean it's not something that you do over
a release cycle it's something that you
do continuously and that accounts for
the activities in the life cycle off
also okay so I think that's the that's
the warm up and now we're back to the
bulldozer I guess I should have
mentioned earlier on you get to decide
for yourself what you think the
bulldozer is pushing around um but the
survey the study that we did in order to
try and answer some of these questions
is is called besom and it's the building
security and maturity model we think
it's the first real data collection from
a fairly wide range of organizations
about what their security practices are
now we sort of live a security guys sort
of inhabit an odd state where
historically speaking people haven't
been very willing to talk about what it
is that they do because they don't want
to be caught out with tomorrow's
vulnerability with point people pointing
at them and saying you made some some
Gamble's and your gambols didn't pay off
so clearly you are negligent right I
think that's sort of what drives people
to be secretive about what they do with
respect to security so I think one of
the things that's novel here is the
degree to which people
willing to describe to us what they do
this really hasn't been never has been
well in the last five years or so hasn't
been much of an issue with Microsoft
where Microsoft has been very open about
what they do from a security perspective
not true for much of the the rest of the
world I sprinkle URLs through a lot of
the rest of this presentation but
they're all they're all available off of
the besom website so don't screw it or
write anything down if you want to
remember one URL that's the that's the
place to go to to get more information
all right so when I say data collection
here's what I'm talking about I'm
talking about instead of going in with a
hypothesis about how soft suffer should
or how security should be built into
software we'll just go ask people who
have been doing it because they haven't
been sharing information to any great
extent for a long time in some sense
they've been conducting largely
independent experiments and we'll look
at where they've ended up in the same
place and where to a certain extent
they've diverged sort of what they ended
up um without knowing it agreeing upon
and which questions aren't necessarily
answered yet for them um so we did this
first by creating a software security
framework so that we could sort of
structure a discussion and try and take
these this diverse set of initiatives
and put them all on the same page and
then by conducting interviews with the
people who were who are in charge of
these initiatives now you got to
remember where I'm starting from I'm
starting from being a guy who likes to
write software and it turns out that in
order to explain why how to use my
software I'm ending up doing interviews
with software executives and writing
down those interviews and trying to sort
of correlate them and coalesce them into
some common sort of form and I am
feeling at this point quite out of my
element feels much more to me like like
anthropology than it does like computer
science and all I guess I can say is
I've tried to go where the work has
taken me I I hope I hope before long
I'll get to return to my roots
writing code but this is what we thought
needed to be done ok so we perform these
in person interviews we did not go down
any sort of checklist we did not go down
any sort of a path where we lead someone
to one answer or another we would merely
asked them to describe what it is they
do in their organizations then we tried
to take those interviews slice them up
identify in them activities that were
being carried out in these organizations
and then map those activities back to
what we heard that that that the
stakeholders were trying to achieve with
them so then we could map an objective
to an activity we came out of these nine
interviews with a hundred and ten
different activities that we saw across
nine organizations we then divided those
hundred and ten activities up into
levels that way we could we could say we
think this organization is more mature
than this other organization when it
comes to one particular breed of
activity and I'll explain more when I
get to explaining the framework please
study successful organizations so we
chose organizations on two on two axes
one is that that they had a significant
dependence on software so software was
important to their business this is fast
disappearing as software becomes
important to just about every business
so as I think you can still argue it's
more important to some and to others and
second of all that the organization was
successful this is a really really
important distinction so I like that you
cannot kind of jump right to it so
what's the right it we believe that
security for the most part plate in most
organizations plays a supporting role in
other words the organization has a
objective for the or the ones that we
looked at here they're all commercial
and they are almost all publicly traded
so their objective is actually written
down in an SEC filing and that is we're
trying to give more money to our
shareholders right and we're trying to
look at at that security organization
has at least done a good enough job in
order to support the mission of the
organization this is not nearly as
uh as fine a point as you'd like to put
on any piece of computer science work
and really does to me at least start
sound a little bit more like
anthropology how important was the
security of the software attended ok
like for example of Microsoft Patrol oh
Jesus Australian we have tons of
attackers trying to find new positive 10
because widely deployed as opposed to
say an organization that I say embedded
system soccer for your refrigerator it's
not clear that you have the same attack
number by doctor this is this is I guess
my first point here weather is the
dependence of the organization on that
on that software working well and I'll
give you a list of company names here
where I think it makes sense not all
these companies are exposed to the same
degree Microsoft is on the list and i
have a feeling you guys understand that
exposure very well some of these
companies are less exposed but they move
a trillion dollars of transactions every
day so um even a small problems to them
can turn into a pretty bad one pretty
quick right some companies failed
because their security department
oh you know Adam I should probably just
let you rattle off the successes and
failures here but I mean like you can
look at at company like heartland which
is not out of the game yet but is
certainly significantly stung by one
incident from late last year you could
look at choice point another payment
processor who is out of the game big for
me more than it was worth the day before
the incident happened I'm so I am
looking somewhat different position on
this which is that most companies that
experience these sorts of problems don't
go out of business that the stock impact
is actually very low on and there's some
work by some folks at CMU that shows
that and the ones we know about
choicepoint TJX and then the two that
actually do go out of business we're in
Paris bellevue-based medical information
processor
current system solutions will have won
the first in credit card but that's a
very very small fraction of all of the
software security failures which raises
some interesting I think I think your
point is is back to can you prove can
you demonstrate this need to build
security into the software I mean it
really good really goes back to that
that initial premise we begin with the
premise that that we think it is it is
critically important to build security
into the software as Adam is saying if
you're if you just want to look at this
from from a stock price point of view
you can't necessarily you can't
necessarily support that easily look at
a place like Microsoft though who has
decided that it's worth investing
significantly in security and I don't
have the time or patience to
second-guess that um so that's really
that's really kind of back to our back
to our premise okay so let's see i
mentioned i mentioned a software
security framework and i have to extend
this is the this is the framework that
we use and i have to explain this
framework so if I can jump from
anthropologie to archaeology for a
second window when the archaeologists
arrive at a new site you they might use
some string to sort of divide up there
their site into quadrants just so that
they can talk about what gets found
where and to a certain extent that's
exactly the same thing that we're doing
with this with a software security
framework which is we just need a way to
talk about a security initiative in some
sort of a generic sense so that we can
can compare very different software
security initiatives this is the
framework that we chose to use you're
never going to find anything like this
in nature there's no there's no there's
no right answer to how to structure an
initiative and there's no reason that
you have to call the the lower
right-hand quadrant configuration
management and vulnerability management
just like there's no particular reason
why you have to take a particular spot
on this on the spectrum and say that
what we defined to be red but it's
really really important for us from a
communication standpoint to just say you
know when I talk about read what I mean
is that right so this is the framework
that we're that we're using we divide it
up into four big domains and then put
three practices in each of those domains
so from just to kind of quickly explain
what we're talking about we define that
first domain to be governance we're
talking about defining what it is you
hope to achieve and how you're going to
measure whether or not you achieved it
or not compliance and policy so trying
to set up specifically what is it you're
trying to get people to do and then
training which is how you tell the rest
of the organization what it is you
expect from them intelligence which
might might better be called knowledge
it's about all the things that you need
to know about attack and defense in
order to carry out your strategy so we
talk about attack models in there we
talk about what is it you want to
incorporate into your design and then
standards and requirements where you
might say we want to achieve a
particular end for our purposes we're
going to standardize on this approach to
solving a particular kind of problem and
then SSTL touch points actually when we
when we got started on this it was
called stl touch points that was until
we arrived here at microsoft and started
talking to you guys and that the word
came back we use the term sdl if you
tell if you call this sdl you'll confuse
the fact that we're participating in
this with with this name you're trying
to be generic so we ended up having to
make a term here to try and to try and
make it clear that we were non-aligned
so sstl is software security development
lifecycle we're talking about things
like you need to review the design we
call that architecture analysis you need
to review the code we call that code
review and then you need to do some some
dynamic testing which we call security
testing one of the things that was
controversial early on when we were
putting together this framework with the
split between security testing and
penetration testing so when a lot of
people get started at this kind of stuff
they they might have somebody come in
and try and and beat up their their code
after
put it in what they think is its final
form that we think of as penetration
testing if it's after the fact we call
it penetration testing if it's part of
what you're trying to do in order to
make sure you built what you intended to
build we call that security testing also
out here in this deployment phase we put
software environment and we also put in
basically change processes so
configuration management vulnerability
management gets lumped down here if you
go and you talk to guys who are
interested in security for more of an
operational perspective they're like
whoa my whole world is this how can you
put it in one little box down in the
corner we say hey look where our focus
is really on on building the right stuff
we have to be able to interface with
these processes but it doesn't dominate
our world okay so here's my logo slide
this is where I get to put up seven of
the nine companies that we looked at in
the in the study and I don't get to put
up two of them the two I don't get to
put up our financial services companies
who aren't as wild about having their
name thrown around with respect to
security the one thing I guess I can say
about them is they're they're both too
big to fail um so the thing I guess
that's important to note about the
slides there's some there's some
diversity here in terms of what these
companies do right so um there's
Microsoft and to a large extent you guys
have have a finger in all pies right um
there's Google who approaches some some
slice of that Adobe also you know they
basically are speculative producers of
software they think customers want
something they make it they try to sell
it to them but then there's a very
different bunch of companies here Wells
Fargo these two guys who shall remain
unnamed who software is really
completely secondary to their existence
they they use software because it's
efficient for running their business but
they don't try and sell a customer based
on the fact that they've got good
software they dtcc also falls in this in
this camp that's the depository trust &
clearing
operation so they're basically the
backend for a lot of Wall Street you
perform a trade it goes to your broker
the broker is going to eventually flow
that transaction through DTCC on the way
to clear to reconciling it with whoever
you traded with um these guys inhabit a
very very different world from a
regulatory perspective and that is
they've got government government
auditors and more government auditors
this year than last year in their
business looking at the way they do
things so not only a software sort of
secondary to them but they've got a lot
more constraints on what on how they
operate their business then then
everybody who's represented here from
the west coast sort of does all right so
along the way we got how we ended up
almost accidentally collecting oh just
this is all information we collected
usually in the first five minutes of an
interview just sort of a tell us a
little bit about you sort of sort of a
thing how long you been at it how long
has there been a software security
initiative in your in your organization
oldest one we studied was ten years
youngest was about two and a half around
average these guys have been at it for
about five years we hope that that means
that many of these organizations have
tried some experiments and to a certain
extent found some things that work and
some things that don't work they have
done a little bit of evolution already
when it comes to security practices um
but but again we didn't we didn't test
that we were just asking about the state
that they're in today we Adam the newest
is two and a half years old is that
because you excluded newer programs that
weren't going to
akhiya you're not new programs in
spelling we we took let's see why how
long was our initial list our initial
list was about 35 organizations who we
think are doing something substantial in
this domain and that's just from from
the the the network of security people
that we know we know about roughly
thirty five big ones we contacted 10 of
them and asked them it because we
thought they were they were fit our
criteria pretty well we got nine except
out of ten to nine people who are
willing to talk to a seven of which
would allow us to use their names and
that's how we chose our sample set so we
did not sort of prejudge those programs
to a great degree although clearly we
are starting with the universe we are
aware of just to study these comfortable
what did you tell them is made out of
you because if somebody came into our
beam envelope a publicist mission I may
try to exaggerate the amount of security
testing in the organization or Foe
longer has the security program right so
and I'm just curious about the social
factor so so there's a you know you ask
you ask somebody for something you know
I might say hey can I have a dollar or I
might say hey will you spend two hours
talking to me right that but but but
still you have to give something up and
what are you going to get in return and
the promise to these organizations in
return was that we would give them a
detailed rundown about where they SAT
with respect to the other companies we
were studying and I'll get back to this
towards the towards the end of the
presentation but that turned out to be a
more powerful lure than that I knew it
was going to be going in partially
because the the people in charge of
these initiatives have a real problem
when they explain what they do to people
outside the security organization
measuring success is very very difficult
and so being able to know what you're
doing compared to your peers and other
organizations is powerful
music the security initiative is that
was what are you talking about people
use I was Paco develop their in-house
software and they're trying to make
their in-house software secure all they
want to check the software they buy from
other song software vendors secure for
their purpose the group that i'm talking
about it Wells Fargo was responsible for
both of those things and they're
specifically responsible for the
business that Wells Fargo conducts on
the Internet ok so now so we've talked
about the age of the initiative next we
can talk about how many people do they
have doing this stuff on average the
average size of the SSG or the software
security group was 41 the smallest one
we looked at a group size of 12 the
biggest was a hundred let's see I'll
come back to a little bit of software
security group size here in just a
little in just a minute um one thing
that we noted pretty early on after
we've done about three interviews is
that everybody was telling us well we've
got this group of people the software
security group and they have security on
their business card right because they
do security their security professionals
but there are all these other people out
there who don't have security on their
business card but we rely on them and
they end up doing a fair amount of
security related stuff a lot of times
they're embedded in product groups or
business units and they really help us
out a lot we eventually saw enough of
this that we gave it a name we called
the the satellite you could think of it
a sort of the extended software security
group and not everybody has one so the
smallest here is size zero some people
have really elaborate systems set up to
try and nurture um sort of a set of
security aficionados in the organization
and that becomes that that software
security group okay so the last quadrant
here is the size of the development
organization this gives you an idea
about how big these these places were
largest 30,000 people write in code
guess who that is smallest organization
that we study
had for 450 people working on software
development um the the average was more
in the thousands or 5,000 5,000
neighborhood um there's a really
important so three orders of magnitude
here right hundreds of developers
thousands of developers tens of
thousands of developers there's one
really important data point left off of
there and that's the that's the
organization's where where all your
software developers can still fit in
your garage right so so how do you do a
good job of building a software when you
are itty bitty how do you do a good job
of building security into your into your
code when you're one guy trying to write
an iphone app and get rich 299 at a time
we don't have any we don't have any idea
about what to tell you about that kind
of stuff we do absolutely just didn't
try and study it it to a certain extent
breaks our model where we're going to
try and take successful organizations
and study them because an organization
if they're if they're itty bitty perhaps
is not successfully the cause they're
never going to be successful or because
they haven't had long enough to be
successful yet and then we don't know
how to study them so the one of the one
of the valid criticisms by heard here is
well hey you know I've got a hundred
people in the entire company what can I
learn from this and I and I think you
have to do some significant reading
between the lines because we can't give
you any direct information about that
watching missing deny is like open
source company
I think right a lot of the code to share
with others we use a lot of open source
code and how they managed their software
could be very different from lack of
microsoft and and is quite quite
different and they've got a different
set of problems there's a there there
are a lot of things missing from here
though government military or
organizations didn't study them they've
got their objectives usually aren't
quite so crisply defined as return value
to shareholders right so they're a
little bit again they cause us trouble
with defining success and they don't
necessarily behave the same the same way
as people who build quite a bit of their
own software all of these are perfect
company so they sell software as a
product but you also have custom more
you know like companies that will do
consulting and create a software
solution that's specific for business
being so the two the two companies that
I didn't name are most equivalent to
wells fargo when you look at that slide
if you look at emc while they do sell a
lot of product they do sell software
products they also sell quite a bit of
software embedded in big systems let's
see dtcc also fells falls into that
Wells Fargo camp Qualcomm is an
interesting one where the primary
product is hardware not software but it
takes quite a bit of software in order
to make that hardware do what you want
it to do so there then you can also look
at a company like Google where you may
be paying them but you're not paying
them for something you go install on
your computer for the most part right so
we did get a fair amount of diversity
here that I think kind of where this
conversation is going is nine data
points in a whole hell of a lot and
that's absolutely true this data is is
fairly hard one though and so we're
going to end up building up this pile a
little bit at a time okay so here's a
list of 10 things that kind of surprised
us coming coming out of this and I don't
think I'm going to go through this list
point by point but we could certainly
pick things here that you
that you guys would would like to talk
about maybe i'll just i'll pick one or
two in order to maybe get started I like
this one a lot evangelize / audit so you
might think that in a saw in a very
technology driven organization where you
ship the software that the security
people were going to have to kind of be
evangelists there we're going to have to
win over developers with rational
arguments about why we're better off
with security and we would be without
security right however if you go to a
place like Wells Fargo you might think
you guys are used to living in a
regulated environment and you're going
to do security because I say so and the
security team would for the most part
wield the stick rather than the carrot
and we did not see that we very
uniformly saw that the carrot is the
winner so that's evangelize over audit
laughs our web application firewalls you
guys generally familiar with web
application firewalls so this whole
notion that instead of a firewall which
which might turn you not allow traffic
through on certain ports or under
certain conditions the idea is we're
going to do the same thing to purely web
traffic and say that HTTP request looks
like an attack and therefore i'm not
going to allow it through that sort of
thing um what we saw is that while is it
nobody nobody we studied is using them
some of them owned them but they don't
use them as firewalls they don't use
them to decide which requests to service
or not they use them in order to try and
understand better how their websites are
being attacked so that was that was
noteworthy to me as to the Microsoft is
curry people
do the software key does security
software development lifecycle I'm
better they wouldn't know if
microsoft.com user what web access our
web application firewall so so usual
thing oh we're studying organizations
that are between big and really big if
you want to ask him about something that
they do do you always do a design review
well the answer is no there's nothing
that happens uniformly absolutely a
hundred percent consistently in a large
organization right and and there's no
one person who knows all of the things
that happened in a large organization
what we're looking for here are are are
what are the big picture items right
we're never going we're never going to
be able to do a study like this or
understand common practices down to
individual lines of code we've got to
look for what are the big trends right
so certainly I certainly if it was the
typical practice that you do not deploy
an application on msn unless it was a
web application firewall believe me
Steve Lipner would know it right dead
and that's the level of resolution of
the data that we've got here what you're
waiting for scared by default frameworks
ok so I'll tell you a little bit about
where I come from at fortify so fortify
makes these products and the products
help people find vulnerabilities in
their code or suggest ways that they
might I make their make their code more
robust and so that's sort of the way I
come at software security well it turns
out that in these in these software
security groups there are a fair number
of people who have that kind of audit
role or they're helping people to audit
or they're doing audit kinds of stuff
but there's a second side to these
groups where instead of trying to sort
of point out weaknesses they're trying
to help people do the right thing the
first time around
that might be by educating them but it's
also by just giving them a piece of code
that does the right thing makes the
audit guy's job a ton easier because
when they come across their own code
they're like we already know how this
thing operates and we know to what
extent we we trust it but everybody is
building code and shipping it into their
into their product units and having
those product units make use of it um
and that's something I didn't didn't
know was it extensive as it is which is
how it made its way out of this list so
again these are not all of the things
that we learned these are the things
that I kind of went well I wouldn't have
guessed that and the reason why that's
important to me is because if you if you
look at sort of the alchemist approach
to doing software security where you
sort of write down all of the things
that kind of makes sense to you you
don't necessarily end up in the same
spot as if you just go ask people what
do you do anybody want to pick something
else off of here then market forces
behind essentially the line intense and
this thing down plus up ah let's see
three nine and ten okay so um I don't
know this seems to be this this Web
Application Firewall business seems to
be at least at least moderately
successful there are still number of
vendors they seem to be head and kind of
down the same path that everybody heads
down when they try and put a new box on
your network and that is eventually sort
of Cisco swallows you right and um that
seems to be moving right along so um I
mean it's not like a runaway hit like
like the original firewall was but it
doesn't seem slated to disappear either
let's see you pointed towards nine the
story a nine is I think a good one so
here's here's sort of my mental image
for how a lot of these software security
initiative get started is something
happens maybe somebody has a bad dream
maybe they've got a big maybe a big
security incident or a series of
security incidents occurs they say huh
looks like software might be kind of a
weak spot for us maybe we need to think
about software in the context of
security what do we do first well do we
really have a problem I mean it seems
like everybody else has a problem but do
we have a problem why don't we go hire
some people and they'll try and break
into the system and we'll find out
whether that problem is real or not
guess what happens when you haven't been
thinking about security too much and
some people try to break into your
system it works right so so all of a
sudden they're there these these guys
these penetration testers who broke into
your system and and can tell you the
different ways that they can prove that
you are weak then you go back and you
like ah hair on fire got to get that
stuff fixed okay you get that stuff
fixed you have the penetration testers
come back in and you're like aha we took
care of that what happens penetration
testers breaking again and then you
start doing like why didn't they tell us
about that stuff the first time and the
fact is they might have had to work a
little harder the second time around but
you know the fact is you were sort of
painting the room with the lights off
and you turn on the lights and you find
out that the room isn't painted the way
you'd like it to be and these guys can
go many many rounds breaking into your
system until you get tired of this game
and you say hey I think we need to start
thinking about building the security and
in the first place so that when we get
around to taking the test we pass it
well what happens then is they put less
emphasis on this penetration testing
they're no longer relying on these
penetration testers to tell them what's
wrong with their code the second
interesting thing here and i'll have to
do it pretty quickly but these
penetration testers never go away so the
interest in penetration testers
diminishes but this outside reflection
or this outside opinion about okay did
we build something that's good enough
seems to be one that hangs around so
interest goes down but it does not
disappear and then you pointed to 10
everybody's fuzzing I and almost
everybody is not like just downloading
some fuzzing tool kit from the internet
and kind of press and go they're putting
some thought into how do they fuzz their
api's and and there and they're doing
good stuff it hasn't been a big
commercial success because nobody's
figured out how do you you know a fuzzer
is a pretty easy thing to write version
1 point 0 of right but it's not
necessarily
an easy thing to make it really really
work well in environment of a particular
company and nobody's cracked the code I
think from a commercial standpoint on
how to make that go that cover what
you're after Ben okay all right so if
you if you go when you take a look at
the besom this is one of twelve skeleton
pages where we outline here all of the
activities related to training so we
list the activity over here the
objective that people are trying to
accomplish by by conducting the activity
over here and then over on this side we
we just you know number the activities
level one here level two here level
three here so for each one of these
activities we we wrote a paragraph that
describes the activity in this
particular case so the idea is that
software security group has office hours
you can pretty quickly you can see how
this is an advocacy activity right when
people just have to do what you say they
have to do they can go read the manual
right then go to read the rules and
regulations and you don't ever have to
talk to them until it's time to take the
test but when you're an advocate you
make yourself available for anybody
who's got any kind of security question
that you want to talk about to come in
and and and talk to you about it right
so at the end of every one of these
paragraphs where we describe this
activity we gave an example the example
here is office hours held one afternoon
per week in the office of a senior
software security group member clearly
that's not the only way you could
satisfy this activity but it's the one
it but we give an example here in every
example we gave is real in other words
one of those nine organizations does
this office our activity this way the
idea is to try and give people a
suggestion about how they might go about
doing this and try and take this this
abstracted view that we've had that
we've built of these nine organizations
and tie it to a real way that activity
is carried out in at least one place I
particularly like this activity because
it's one that fortify invented on it
12 so our research group ends up
partitioning its time such that if you
want to come in if you work at fortify
and you want to ask a security question
to a researcher you've got two times a
week you can come in and you know
somebody will be there ready to talk to
you okay so you take all of those
activities you take a vector that
describes everything that an
organization does and then you can give
them a scorecard so we take the 12
different practices and and then we take
and then we measure the organization and
we we really really struggled with how
do you measure an organization how am I
going to say whether Microsoft's
training work is at two or a three right
how would you how would you say that
well we looked at a lot of different
ways to do it and eventually what we
found is that high water mark was just
about as good as anything else by high
water mark I mean if on our list of
activities we saw we observed one
activity at level three for an
organization we called that
organizational level three you could
theoretically not do any level one
activities any level two activities just
do a level three activity and you're
there now that that's a fairly low
resolution approach to trying to give
someone a score for the data set that we
had it came out just about as well as
trying to do an average or a weighted
average of the of the numbers and it was
really simple to compute so it's easy to
explain it's easy to compute that's what
that's the information of presenting
here so then what you can do is you can
take an individual organization
represented here in blue and overlay it
on the average represented here in red
and you can give people a quick sort of
take on how do they compare to the
average over over the study set that we
had people people really dig this stuff
I remember kind of graduating from high
school and thinking that I was sort of
happy to de-emphasize the report cards
in my life you know um but apparently at
some point people get around to missing
them I'm going to jump forward and show
the expanded version of that report card
here and then I'll go
to the previous slide so here's the the
detail on that on that score card and I
have to have to do quite a bit of
unpacking to try and explain what were
what we're representing here so maybe i
should say this first we observed a set
of ten activities that everybody does
and my definition of everybody here is a
little bit liberal when i say everybody
I mean eight of the organization's we
studied or nine of the organization's we
studied so we gave ourselves just a
little bit of leeway when we defined
everybody so the the things in green
here are things where this hypothetical
organization did one of the activities
everybody does right so green is good
maybe I should explain this this chart a
little bit better so every one of the
hundred and ten activities is listed so
like here you know here's the training
section down here then the next column
is how many of the nine organizations
carried out each of those activities and
then this column right here is the
particular organization that this report
card is for right so you can see nine
out of nine organizations did training
1.1 and because nine out of nine did it
of course this organization did it too
so that's in green in red are the things
where everybody else does it but you
don't right so let's see when we find
one in red here that well pick that
architecture analysis one point three
eight out of nine organizations did it
this organization didn't do it so okay
so what does it mean if everybody else
does it and you don't do it I can think
of two things that it might mean so the
so like for instance here if you see
like a nine here but there's a red
square here that's because this date is
made up we wanted to show a
representative scorecard without showing
anybody in particular scorecard um so
what does it mean if everybody else does
it and you don't do it it might mean
that you are oh I don't I'll pick your
favorite synonym for negligent right
you're just not very good right or it
might mean you're so sophisticated you
don't need to do that anymore right hey
we could it could we don't know we don't
know what it means we think it's
probably interesting for that
organization to understand though so red
things are things that you probably need
to understand okay so other than we've
covered green we've covered red now we
should cover blue so I showed earlier a
chart where where I was comparing the
average in red to blue which represented
that particular company if you were
below average in a particular area then
we picked out a few activities that
would bring you up to average or take
you beyond average and we did that
purely based on on the prevalence of
those activities in the data so for
instance here the strategy and metrics
is this column has kind of shaded blue
because they're behind the organization
is behind average but hey sm 2.1 seven
out of nine organizations did it maybe
that's something you'd like to think
about because it seems that a lot of
people do it and it would at least take
you up to average in that area right so
purely analytically driven suggestions
about the kinds of activities that you
might want to consider is what we get
out of the blue let's see in the back
fun to talk to these organizations we
youth of this sport car try to ask them
why they didn't do this gratis so this
this in fact was the was the promise
that we made them when we went in and
gathered the data was that we would come
back around give them these scorecards
and talk them through them now there's
we can tell them what you know what
strategy and metrics 2.1 is and how we
define that to go in and try and to help
them to get there is it beyond our
abilities to do as part of a study so we
think that people got a lot at least at
we're very interested in seeing these
scorecards and comparing themselves what
they're doing with the information I
don't know our intention is to go back
to them after a year and find out what's
changed so we hope to get a little bit
of information there but you can't
really get it instantly something just
because everyone is doing that why is it
necessarily a good thing to me you could
be just going through the motions
without actually investing in that
process right so I'm incredible why
you're saying being equals good ah well
I think that the the large the larger
version of that question is
effectiveness in other words maybe
everybody is doing it everybody is doing
a particular activity the same way
everybody has an appendix all right
they've got it but it's not clear what
exactly it's it's doing for them we're
trying to be v we're trying to be very
we're trying to really set ourselves
apart from the alchemists here in that
we are we're trying to study what people
are doing but not necessarily make a
value judgment about about whether
that's an effective activity or whether
that's something that they need to be
doing or not so maybe maybe these good
and bad here's some place where is a
place where I've stepped over the line
trying to trying to label these i should
say i should say you're running with the
pack and you're not running with the
pack right i think that would be a
better representation
so your premise seems to be more is
always better here which I agree as a
good premise if your goal is to build
software security organizations or
suffer security grips if your goal is to
maximize profitability that executive
from oh sorry would look at this and say
here's all the things I'm doing that
most other people aren't we should cut
those out of our budget because it's not
necessary so how do you how you make the
case of you if you're doing things that
other people aren't should you be so two
things that I would emphasize here one
uh let's see what's the what's the right
way to come come at this one way to get
a perfect score here would be to do
everything you do 110 activities there
for you you get a perfect score but you
might remember according to our scoring
system all you have to do is one
activity at level 3 in order to be
graded at a level 3 therefore the least
expensive way to get a perfect score
here would be to do 12 things and to
just pick those 12 things from from the
the level three activities right the
we're not trying to come up with a
system here that can't be gained we're
trying to come up with a good way to
describe what we what we saw right so
you know we went out into the jungle and
we saw monkeys eating bananas and is
that a good thing or a bad thing or two
deserve a better way for those monkeys
to eat the bananas I don't know um now
now we might be able to take this data
and get there someway someday but it's
certainly not what we're after here
I think that most of the organizations
that are making this investment believe
they have a business reason to be gentle
but what's really interesting to me is
that let's say you're an organization
who is getting started doing this you
can actually start to use this to say
these are the things that everybody does
it's reasonable to think that if not if
everybody is doing it they probably have
found valuable doesn't necessarily mean
you well but it's a really organizations
really struggle hard with how to West
Sarge and I think that's worth me one of
the huge values of this being toddler is
you can look to the green items you look
to the nines and say nobody who is doing
this doesn't offer to invest in them
I think that's I think that's not the
way people I think it's easier for you
to say that is for me and I think that's
exactly right because you're starting to
your start and put value on those things
and say hey people invest in this stuff
because they find it useful but but it's
possible that it was useful at one point
and they kept doing it past when it was
useful don't know so I list here I'm not
going to be able to talk about this
because we're over time now so I'm going
to try and wind up here in just a minute
or two but we list the 10 things that
that everybody does I'll tell you
everybody does good network and host
security it's if you're if you can't
install a web server and get it up and
running right if you don't have a
reliable way to put a new host on the
network you probably don't need to be
thinking about this stuff yet right so
there are more interesting things in
here evangelism comes up again a lot of
organizations think that training is one
of the most critical things that they do
when it when it comes to software
security they all roll their own history
into the training so it's not like
buffer overflow is bad it's more like
let us tell you about where we've been
burned on buffer overflow before you
comment a little about that i'll be
using tools that are in now sir standard
to static advice from 45 community
they use tools they use a combination of
tools that they built themselves that
they've bought commercially there's
let's see there's not as clear there's
not one right answer for for skinning
that one what is clear is that doing
code review oh you need to do code
review and you don't want to do it all
with eyeballs okay so let's see you know
this seems to be one of these topics
that was sort of to a certain extent in
the water and if if we didn't publish
about it somebody was going to publish
about it sooner or later so there I
wanted to point out a couple of other
things that sort of tend towards
maturity model that are that are in the
mix there's the Software Assurance
maturity model Sam also known as open
Sam which actually is a was the
precursor to the BCAM work so I hired
premier John Doe to create this we
basically were doing a little bit more
alchemy and we looked at it when it was
done and we said oh gosh we're a little
dissatisfied with with the idea that we
just sort of aggregated a set of good
ideas let's go out and try and study
some stuff but we'd shown that's that
that project around to enough people the
OWASP crowd had kind of latched on to it
so it's out there and I don't think it
hurts anything but I don't think it's
particularly revolutionary you either um
we found out I when we were about
halfway through with this work about the
Microsoft stl optimization model which
which is of course the way that you take
the the Microsoft sdl and kind of trying
up build a little bit bigger builds more
of an initiative rather than trying to
think about the sdl as a static kind of
a beast we think that we're providing
data that could power just about any
model so we publish as part of the beast
and report how many times we observed
each of these activities and if you
don't like the way we ranked these
activities if you don't like the fact
that we left a couple of things off you
can still use our data set and we hope
people do use our data set to support
other hypotheses all right so i'll put
the i'll put the URL up there one last
time i'll make just a few closing
comments about
about the BCM work we think it's useful
as a yardstick we think it's useful for
for people to figure out to measure
their own initiative we think it's
useful maybe to start looking around and
thinking about what you might want to
change about your initiative we think
though as a yardstick and as something
we put out there under a Creative
Commons license some people are going to
take that yardstick and they're going to
crack it up and roast a hot dog with it
and that's okay I think that's the
that's the kind of price you pay when
you decide to start trying to do some of
the stuff in the open rather than just
say oh I heard about a company that did
this once and I think that'd be a good
idea for you you got to expect some
abuse along the way and we're okay with
that we're trying really hard though to
get away from this world of alchemy
where people mostly win with either the
credentials they put behind their name
or with the the forcefulness of their
rhetoric and trying to start to base
some of this stuff on on principles that
look a little bit more like science we
don't think that there where we're going
to get to a point where where there's a
right way to do software security so we
looked a lot of organizations they've
got a lot of different forces acting on
them what's interesting is when those a
lot of different forces drive them all
to doing some of the similar is the most
similar thing so I think that list of 10
common things is a really powerful
outcome from from this work however we
don't expect we'll get to a point where
we're ever going to give you a formula
or a recipe for here's what your
organization has to do I'm pretty well
over time but I'm happy to hang around
here for for a while after the
presentation if you guys want to
continue the discussion thanks for your
attention
I mean are you can endure you know what
girl and here is enough of a recipe to
get organizations k in their practices
or do you think that need to be other
stuff that need to be done so I think
there's an initial decision where you
choose to invest seriously in building
more secure software and we're not
really building the case for that once
you have made that decision what should
you do first what should you do after
that those are the kinds of questions
that we've addressed there are a couple
of things we've already discussed in
this in this hour where I think we're
weak and that is nine data points is not
enough and I think we don't really have
any advice for people at the low end
security people are just famous like you
call them up and you're like I got a
security problem and they're like you
need to do a called me yesterday right
they all a security guys always always
say that and yet we can't talk to the
smaller organizations yet and we need to
find some sort of a way to to address
that so I think there's a lot more we
can do in terms of filling in this
picture I'm reasonably happy with it
with the high level outline that we've
built I don't think we'll ever stop in
technology is a need for data boy well
we get to this methodology question we
we tried well we don't know how to
answer yet which is how do you judge
success in a small organization so I
don't think we've we've answered that
yet and um I wasn't trained to be an
anthropologist so I'm quite willing to
believe that I've got a lot to a lot to
learn there although I I hope that we've
got we've got useful stuff in this first
round i'm sure there's plenty more we
can do to make that to make that better
if you've got ideas I'd love to I'd love
to hear about Adam will you up next
I have two questions that are sort of
related which is you step failure either
at the organizational or activity like
what activities of people stop to join
and are there orange that tried to do
this didn't see one of the things that
came out of this work that isn't really
represented in this presentation is a
long long list of anecdotes and we chose
early on when we when we started sifting
through our data to try and concentrate
on what people were doing today and what
they presented in a way that led us to
believe they were going to continue to
do it along the way we got a bunch of
interesting information about stuff that
they had either stopped doing or just
horror stories because you know you sit
down with a security guy before long
we're talking horror stories right um so
for instance we talked to a number of
people who had really really felt like
they'd been burned by bad metrics so
they knew they had to measure because
you work in a big company you're gonna
have to measure something especially in
the security realm where you know not
being broken into tomorrow doesn't
necessarily mean anything right they had
put metrics in place that they thought
did the right thing they'd found people
were were changing their behavior um
because they knew about the metric but
they weren't getting the behavior they
wanted out of them and let's see let me
think of other failure cases that's the
one that immediately jumps to mind I've
got a I've got out I've got a file full
of these things and I'm still trying to
figure out how to how to present
I think means of data that can be
interesting to study is how these
organizations reward this kind of effort
for exam
security problems do you penalize the
security people or paralyze the
developer generating produce that's
um the reward system um well we got I'll
give you I'll give you just another
another anecdote there so here's my
favorite reward system a trick that I
learned as part of this work so remember
the security group has the sort of
extended circle of people that they that
they work with right so here's what the
guy in charge of the security
organization does it comes around to
reviews and it's it's time for the time
in the year where we're doing reviews
and raises well the the guy in charge of
security takes the fit his favorite 10
developers who've done the best job for
him and writes a lengthy and glowing
praise letter for them and make sure
that it gets to the desk of the manager
of that person and what he finds is over
a period of years people who do better
at security tend to get promoted and
they tend to have more power in the
organization and this feeds very nicely
on what the director of security wants
so I mean there's an example where the
security guy is trying to affect the
reward system we saw very very
inconsistent data about training about
whether or not people track whether or
not people whether or not the
organization has been trained some of
them can say there was a point in 19 or
in 2005 we're all developers had been
trained um and now we don't know we just
don't know anything about who's been
trained and who hasn't and so there's a
place where they're good or kind of
inconsistent about it I think you're
right you could I can tell you I didn't
acai I didn't see any instances where
the beatdown really hits the security
guys when there's an incident didn't
didn't hear that from anybody who felt
like they were going to have the rug
pulled out from them in terms of
organizational power on the next
incident nobody nobody represented that
the mindset of developers is
dry as a developer on the security or
with the other garment which is a
security department on the sphere of
myself Michael this can be for the most
part I think the organization's we're
looking at are kind of over that and
it's very very you can push this analogy
too hard but you can think about
software quality kind of in the in the
in the same vein where you say who's
responsible for quality is certainly not
the person who is due who's trying to
measure quality right good a little bit
hostile somewhat impressive essay I
really like this work I think it's very
useful but I think a more appropriate
title would be the beginning of alchemy
not in developing that this is really
getting us from the pre alchemy stage to
the alchemy stage where you know where
people are starting to share information
you're learning what other people are
doing we don't have sort of scientific
understand a understanding of the
fundamental limits or ways of measuring
things and if we were goal is to go
beyond alchemy to get to something
empirical which which is what you're
claiming we would need ways of actually
measuring how well things actually work
not just understanding
effectiveness this comes down to two do
I I think it comes back to the
effectiveness things like okay you did
static analysis well is that actually
doing anything for you or did you do it
because it's some sort of popularity
contest right I mean I think you're I
think you're absolutely right k in in
that this is not going to be the only
sort of metric that you might measure an
organization by and it does not directly
address this this question of
effectiveness I think though well maybe
and maybe this is part of your point to
I think though that just like you know
Lord Kelvin like basically he just
started kind of make some tick marks on
the on the glass and measuring where the
mercury was and those tick marks didn't
really mean anything in and of
themselves even though now we call them
degrees and we find them very useful is
to start kind of coming up with this
common vocabulary for talking about this
kind of stuff is the is the starting
line for science which which I'd want to
divide from from alchemy let them go